*bruit*
Ah vous êtes là? Comment-allez vous? *cris woh*
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel est ce un simple problème d'électronique ou un poltergeist a provoqué ce qui vient de se passer
ah oui on est là pour se faire peur oui oui oui les amis aujourd'hui je ne vais pas vous lire un thread twitter ou redit
ou quoi que ce soit mais je vais vous parler de mes trois histoires d'horreur
préférés dont l'une qui est celle qui m'a fait mettre un pas dans le paranormal et qui m'a fait adorer ça et surtout adoré les
films d'horreur c'est vraiment grâce à cette histoire là voilà je vais devoir un peu synthétiser tout ça puis je mettais des sources dans la
description s'il y en a  qui veulent lire avec précision certains trucs je trouve ça passionnant on commence avec
l'exorcisme de michel anne lise
ouais p'tet je vais me reconvertir dans la voix off ouais
il s'agit du cas de possession démoniaque le plus connu de l'histoire et l'un des plus
documenté il ya même eu deux films dessus tellement cette histoire est connue c'est celle ci qui m'a fait plonger dans le paranormal je vais
vous la conter avec un plaisir démesuré et Anne Lyse michel est une jeune allemande né le 21 septembre
1952 à leiblfing en bavière
je ne parlerai plus allemand désolée elle fait partie d'une famille catholique très croyante elle va jusqu'à faire pénitence pour faire pardonner les péchés des
autres en plus des siens elle est vraiment impliqué dans le péché game vraiment tout se passe bien jusqu'à ses 16 ans donc jusqu'en 68
ou là elle commence à avoir des crises de convulsions elle est alors diagnostiqué
épileptique par les médecins mais ça ne va pas s'arrêter là
son état continue de se détériorer les crises sont plus en plus nombreuses et il pense du coup qu'il ya un problème psychologique derrière ça
alors il l'envoie dans un hôpital psychiatrique pendant une année ça ne s'améliore pas c'est même pire qu'avant en plus de ça elle elle tombe
en dépression donc c'est vraiment la totale pour la pauvre Anne Lyse michel qui va alors commencer à parler de
possession démoniaque elle va commencer à être
persuadé qu'elle est possédée par des démons à tel point qu'elle va se mettre à rejeter les symboles catholiques comme les
crucifix , la bible tous ça elle va se mettre à chier là-dessus vraiment comme si elle en voulait à
l'église de ne rien faire pour elle alors qu'elle est convaincue qu'elle est possédée elle le crie sur tous les toits sa situation va ensuite
s'arranger elle va sortir de l'hôpital elle va reprendre
le chemin de la foi elle va se remettre à prier à croire mais elle surveille ces derrières elles gardent quand même une petite fiole
d'eau bénite tu vois dans la poche arrière au cas où il ya un démon bam dans la gueule à partir de là la pauvre
c'est une descente aux enfers *wheu* à proprement parler puisqu'on parle de démons et tout anne lise va se remettre à parler de possessions démoniaques
même plus que ça elle va commencer à dire qu'elle voit des visages démoniaque elle va se mettre aussi entendre des voix de
entité diabolique
elle est convaincue que ces médicaments n'arrange rien elle en prend pour traiter ces problèmes d'épilepsie pour traiter sa dépression pour traiter même la
schizophrénie je crois enfin bref les médecins il s'acharne un peu sur elle donc du coup elle va arrêter d'un coup de prendre tous ces
médicaments et c'est une très mauvaise idée
pendant toutes ces années l'église
refuse de pratiquer un exorcisme sur anne lise étant donné qu'elle est persuadée d'être possédé ça a un effet très destructeur pour elle mais en 75
un curé va porter l affaire devant
l'église va les convaincre de pratiquer des exorcismes au cours des exorcismes les prêtres diagnostic que il y aurait plusieurs
entités qui sont rentrés dans le corps de anne lise entre autres néron
lucifer et hitler le comportement d'anne lise est de pire en pire elle
hurle, elle mort les prêtres elle se met même à manger des insectes elle va commencé à se mutiler aussi bref tous les signes que l'église considère
comme des signes de possession démoniaque elle les a et surtout il ya un enregistrement audio qui a été fait lors d'un
exorcisme et là on entend
la voix de Anne Lise et qu'elle soit posséder ou pas on s'en fout c'est assez troublant parce qu'on entend quand même une personne en détresse
mais un très court extrait qui vous fera badé mais pas trop non plus mais c'est vous dire à quel point
c'est sérieux en fait ce qui s'est passé avec cette personne c'est pas une légende
Le premier juillet 76
Anne Lise décède elle meure a l'âge de 25 ans après des années de souffrance et cette histoire a fait d'elle le cas de possession démoniaque le plus
connu de l'histoire ça c'est l'histoire comme les gens aiment la raconter si sauf qu'il y a eu un
décor qui est beaucoup plus glauque après ça c'est à dire qu'il ya un procès qui a commencé en mars 78
et qui accusait en fait les prêtres qui ont pratiqué des exorcismes et les parents d'anne lise de
négligence entraînant la mort d'une personne
le procès était assez
dingue et emblématique parce que ça opposait l'église qui parlait de faits surnaturels comme de possession démoniaque à la science les médecins qui a expliqué
que le comportement d'anne lise était lié à
tous les médicaments qu'elle prenait leurs effets secondaires et aussi à l'arrêt brutal de cela c'est dire que c'est des traitements lourds et quand t'arrêtes
en plein milieu ça mais ton cerveau un peu en bordel résultat du procès les parents d'Anne Lise et les prêtres furent condamnés à six mois de
prison avec sursis
pourquoi parce qu'en fait si il y avait eu non lieu
ça donnait raison aux prête d'avoir eu ces pratiques là sur anne lise et serait surtout montré que la justice voit la possession démoniaque comme
une réalité et non plus comme un mythe ou quelque chose de paranormal mais on n'a pas de preuves que ça existe vraiment voilà ça c'est
ouf comme histoire ça opposait vraiment le paranormal et la science est ce qui est horrible c'est que les symptômes d'une possession démoniaque
si ça existe sont vraiment très très proches voire exactement les mêmes que les effets secondaires de certains médicaments que tu prends quand un traitement
lourd en contre certains problèmes psychologiques entre autres donc du coup ce procès était
compliqué et ça rend l'histoire assez folle et en tout cas Anne Lise Michèle paix à son âme et c'est horrible ce qu'elle a
vécu et voilà que ce soit une procession démoniaque ou juste un problème psychologique c'est affreux bon maintenant que vous n'allez pas dormir bah autant que je
continue je vous raconte une deuxième histoire je suis le père castor de ma génération l'histoire de robert la poupée ralala cette voix
Robert the doll une histoire qui m'a marqué de ouf parce que c'est l'une des rares histoires qui contient une poupée hanté bah je crois que
c'est la seule en fait avec annabelle et surtout cette putain de poupées elle a une geule un peu
atypique on a souvent parlé poupée dans les vidéos mais regardez-moi ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça qui à design et ce truc en
1906 robert Eugène Otto est un jeune enfant qui vit en floride et qui se voient offrir une
poupée il est encore enfant à ce moment là quand il reçoit la poupée elle fait carrément sa taille et c'est la servante de la
famille de la maison originaire des bahamas qui lui a offert cette poupée et elle est vue
comme une personne qui pratique un peu la magie noire et le vaudou la théorie c'est qu'elle a offert cette poupée aux
fils de la famille pour se venger du calvaire qu'elle vivait à cause d'eux alors robert trouvait que la poupée lui ressemblait donc il lui
a donné son nom au calme la poupée s'appelle donc robert et lui il se faisait appeler par sa famille par son deuxième prénom eugène pour moi j'ai
un gros début de schizophrénie mais ainsi soit il
il va rapidement y avoir un problème avec cette poupée
cet enfant puisque les parents ils entendent Eugène parler a Robert dans sa chambre ils entendent deux voix différentes c'est ça qui est glauque alors les
enfants ont souvent des amis imaginaires où en tout cas ils en créé donc ils se disent que leur fils
interprète tout simplement la voix de sa poupée robert ainsi que la sienne et il converse à sa poupée sauf qu'en fait il c'est lui
qui fait les questions et les réponses
quelques années plus tard les parents vont changer d'avis parce que là il ne va plus être question de simple petite conversation entre les deux ils entendent la
poupée crier sur ce Eugène et lui donner des ordres
au calme robert il prend un melon mon pote t'a jamais vu ça les parents ont même dit que quand ils entraient dans la chambre
et voyait eugène dans un coin de la pièce en pls et robert posé sur une chaise au calme
eh t'est une poupée tu redescends mon pote ok souvent quand les parents rentraient chez eux après être allé en vacances ou
cinéma il retrouvait des trucs cassé dans la maison et le pauvre Eugène il avait rien fait du coup il répondait robert did it  c'est à
dire c'est robert qui a fait ça
cette phrase aujourd'hui elle est connu un peu dans les familles en floride quand un gamin fait une bêtise il dit robert did it tellement c'est
vous dire à quel point l'histoire
de robert the doll est connue là-bas
le temps passe les années passent les parents d'Eugène décède c'est triste mais c'est la vie c'est comme ça que ça se passe
Eugène se retrouve alors à vivre dans la maison de ses parents sans ses parents bon c'est un adulte maintenant il a 30 enfin tu
vois là il se retrouve donc avec une chambre en trop et qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'on a une poupée en trop une chambre en trop et
bah on unit les deux voilà pour que la poupée ai sa petite chambre à elle
Eugène c'est quoi la Eugène va ensuite étudié l'art à
paris puis
revient vivre dans cette fameuse maison des années plus tard avec son épouse Anne Eugène il continue de parler à robert la poupée
Anne elle se dit mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel ça dure ça dure ça dure et un jour elle fait j'en ai marre
elle négocie robert ça dégage ça va au
grenier voilà et là c'est très très glauque puisque les voisins vont se mettre à aller voir Eugène en lui disant mec il y a un truc dans ton
grenier qui bouge robert la poupée se met aux fenêtres du grenier puis bouge passe d'une fenêtre à l'autre calmement
ok mais eugène refuse de jeter robert à la poubelle
anne ça va la rendre folle folle folle folle folle quelques années plus tard Anne décède paix à son âme
et il y a plein de voisins qui pensent que
robert did it on arrive à
74  eugène
décès , la maison est vendue une famille vient emménager là et il y a toujours robert au grenier bah oui c'est soit son foyer a lui et c'est
ouf parce que la famille a constaté que leur petite fille de 10 ans se mettait a
développer une relation imaginaire avec cette poupée avec robert et on peut voir robert dans une cloche en verre
dans un fort qui est devenu je crois un musée des horreurs ou je sais plus trop quoi mais bref et en fait quand on passe devant
il faut lui demander la permission de prendre une photo et apparemment il aurai hanté quelques visiteurs du truc
quoi qu'il en soit c'est génial l'histoire avec les poupées enfin c'est génial a lire, vivre c'est un peu moins génial apparemment cette histoire là
m'avait aussi énormément fait kiffer et puis surtout la gueule atypique de la poupée quoi mec c'est fou
n'est-il pas temps de passer à la troisième histoire The Enfield Poltergeist
Eh pas dégueu celui la alors déjà qu est ce qu un poltergeist
ça vient du coût de l'allemand poltergeist c'est le dérivé de poltern terme qui veut dire faire du bruit et geist qui veut dire esprit
il s'agit donc d'un phénomène paranormal consistant en des bruits divers des déplacements apparitions disparitions d'objets ou autre phénomène a priori
inexplicable oui j'étais sur wikipédia m'en bat les couilles nous sommes en
1977 à enfield une ville
d'angleterre Peggy Hodgson vie dans une petite maison avec ses quatre enfants et elle va être témoin de phénomènes paranormaux
ça va partir en couille et j'adore cette histoire déjà parce qu'elle a inspiré mon film d'horreur préféré
conjurer 2 et surtout parce que c'est le cas d'apparition de phénomènes paranormaux le plus documenté de
l'histoire du poltergeist en vrai il y  aurait matière à faire une vidéo
juste sur cette histoire là mais vu qu'elle est extrêmement connu et que d'autres ont déjà fait je vais pas vous faire ça je vais
juste vous dire les grands traits de l'histoire et pour les curieux vous allez voir en détail mais c'est hyper intéressant
Peggy Hodgson vit dans une petite maison à Endfiels comme je ne vous le dire et elle élèves ses quatre enfants là bas
margaret 13 ans janet 11 ans johnny 10 ans et billy 7 ans
nous sommes le 31 août aux alentours de 21h donc c'est pas très tard en plus et peggy est posée dans sa chambre en train
de dormir lorsqu'elle entend un
crissement qui vient de la chambre des enfants elle rejoint la chambre en courant les deux enfants son réveillés relevé dans leur lit et disent putain
maman on a peur il faut savoir que la veille ses enfants lui avaient dit ah maman au secours nos lit bouge tout seul au
secours nos lit bouge tout seul cette fois ci c'était la chaise qui apparemment bougeait toute seule Peggy calmes les enfants elle regagne sa chambre mais
elles rentent en un petit glissement bizarre elle retourne dans la chambre et là il ya quatre toques qui proviennent des murs de la maison
comme du coeur de la maison et là la
commode donc une commode c'est très lourd qui est située contre un mur ce met a ce
décollé du mur et a bouger comme s'il y avait une
entité qui l'a poussé vraiment avec une force démesurée ce qui fait un peu flipper quand même donc sur le coup peggy
elle a pas d'explication rationnelle à ce qui vient de se passer elle prend une sage décision c'est venez tous
on dort tous dans le salon ensemble
c'est la meilleure idée peggy va alors aller chercher de l'aide auprès de ses voisins en les suppliant de venir dans sa maison pour inspecter
avec elle parce qu'il s'est passé un truc pas très normal quand même alors ils vont commencer à se balader dans la maison et il ya
ces fameux toc toc qui vont continuer
d'apparaître mais ils apparaissent toujours autour de la ou peggy et ses voisins se trouve dans la maison c'est comme si quelqu'un était enfermée dans
les parois de la maison est toquais à l'endroit où ils sont en se déplaçant  en même temps que pour leur faire peur aux alentours de
23 heures ils ont toujours pas d'explication logique donc peggy elle se dit bon bah ça se trouve c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui est venu dans
la maison donc dans le doute je vais appelé la police pour qu'ils enquêtent la police se remmène
il rentre dans la maison tout est très calme d'un coup il réentende les fameux toc toc et là l'un des fauteuils du salon ce
met a glisser d'environ
1 m sur le sol les policiers qu'est ce que tu veux qu'ils fassent
si c'est un truc paranormal c'est un truc paranormal les flics y peuvent rien faire c'est pas eux qu' il faut appeler qu'il faut appeler
* musique de ghost buster*
peggy contacte la presse et c'est un gars de la presse qui est sensible à ça il s'appelle george falloz  et il va sur les lieux
il entend les fameux coups et décide de contacter un
organisme pour gérer l'affaire ça fait la une de plusieurs journaux tout le monde parle de ça
souvent il ya des journalistes des enquêteurs devant la maison bref du coup la famille vit un enfer ils sont fatigués ont du mal à
dormir en plus ya ça à partir de là les manifestations surnaturelles se
multiplie et elle semble être centrée autour de janet par exemple c'est janet qui se réveille en pleine nuit avec une sensation de
suffoquer comme si quelqu'un lui avait pincer le nez et mis
une mains sur la bouche c'est vers djanet que les objets volent bref ça a l'air vraiment d'être autour d'elle maurice grosse qui fait partie
du fameux institut qui enquête sur le paranormal est régulièrement
chez
la famille de peggy pour être témoins des phénomènes et voir ce qu'il peut faire comme je vous ai dit c'est souvent autour de djanet
que ça se passe et une nuits janet se réveille en hurlant elle bouge dans  tout les sens elle est excitée maurice essaye  de la
calmer mais il se fait mordre ça finit par une petite injection d'un produit pour la calmer et au final elle est diagnostiqué schizophrène
ça fait un peu penser justement au cas Anne Lise c'est ça qui est horrible a partir  de la ya plein de photos de djanet qui
vont être prises janet qui volent contre la radio la célèbre photo de djanet qu'il évite au dessus de son lit
même si on dirait qu'elles sotent la clairement et alors du coup voilà ça qui est horrible est ce que tout ça est un gros
fake organisée par la famille ou est-ce que c'est réel les enquêteurs s'enchaînent les médiums s'enchaînent ya un nombre de gens qui passent dans cette
maison pour voir ça et pour essayer d'arranger la situation c'est incalculable
l'histoire prend fin en 78 genres ya tellement de trucs paranormaux dans la maison qu'ils sont habitués genre janet quand elle se couche
elle est projetée hors du lit elle se met à voler c'est normal ça devient normal
il y a alors une décision qui est prise c'est qu'elle aille en hôpital psychiatrique elle va dans le meilleur hôpital psychiatrique du monde
elle va y rester trois mois avant de rentrer chez elle et à partir de là tout se calme même s'il ya encore des fois
des témoignages d'apparition de la part des enfants de Peggy ils disent avoir vu un vieux monsieur ou un enfant et voit la fin de l'histoire
janet est toujours en vie et elle a témoigné plein de foi de tout ça de son enfance un peu
mouvementée et alors la question est gros problèmes psychologiques
ou vrai poltergeist comme pour anne lise c'est ça qui est fou avec ses histoires j'adore les amis j'espère que ça vous a plus n'hésitez pas aimé
la vidéo si c'est le cas et j'espère vous n'allez pas vous mettre
à voler au dessus de votre lit cette nuit qui aura pas de poltergeist qu'il y aura pas des toc toc qui viennent des murs
tout ça qu'il y aura pas robert the doll sous le lit qui met des petits coups comme ça entre deux latte pour vous empêcher de dormir voilà je
voulais trop parler de ces trois histoires parce qu'elles sont fascinantes et elles sont
extrêmement documenté enfin c'est les deux cas de possession démoniaque de poltergeist qui sont les plus connus est pas pour rien quoi
celui là celui de djanet le nombre de photos de témoignages de vue c'est
incroyable je vous fais plein de bisous
j'espère que ces petits trucs ou on parle d'histoires d'horreur vous font kiffer  moi j'adore p'tin je kiffe tellement je suis vraiment content d'avoir pu vous
raconter ces trois histoires là qui m'ont
fasciné c'est vraiment grâce à ça que j'ai aimé le paranormal et je me suis mis à mis intéresser même si j'y crois pas en
fait j'ai jamais voler au dessus de mon lit comme janette tu vois je peux pas y croire du coup mais bon ceux qui y
croient je respecte en attendant je vous fais des gros bisous bonne nuit
*Musique*